vp you have the floor
good morning
today was not the following affairs
ministers
who deserve a rest after four meetings
in a week
today he convinced the defense ministers
because at the end
in practical terms and once the
political decision was taken yesterday
is a matter of defense policy
and it's up to the defense ministers to
implement these measures and to use this
funding
the first purpose of this meeting was
to assess the evolution of the military
situation on the ground
and the military staff of the european
union has provided us with a value
assessment
of this situation gathering all the
intelligence information
that the member states contribute to our
assessment and awareness of the
situation
certainly the military campaign the
russian military campaign is becoming
more and more ruthless
and ukrainian armed forces
are fighting back with courage
keith resist
for the ones who said that was matter of
fact matter of hours
the fall of keith
this is not the case keith is resisting
are you probably resisting car coffees
are resisting
there are a lot of civilian casualties
and the flow of exile people
don't call them migrants please
the flow of people looking for
shelter escaping the war
is increasing especially in the polish
border
we got the figures
of all member states who have a border
with ukraine about the flow of refugees
i insist don't call them migrants please
in this situation our support for the
ukrainian air forces is crucial crucial
they need ammunitions to new healthcare
material
they need a defensive purpose arms of
any kind
and we are going to provide them
together by
with the member states adding up to the
efforts of some member states
the resources that we decided to
mobilize yesterday from the european
funding
and everyone
everyone
said everyone
agreed on that
so member states are determined to
increase their military
support on a bilateral basis to ukraine
and to top up
this effort with
the funding of the european union
in order to repel
the unacceptable action by putin
who is implementing this aggression to
ukraine with the support of lukashenko
who by the way is organizing today a
constitutional referendum
in a context of oppression and
widespread human rights violations he's
organizing a referendum
to delete belarus
non-nuclear status from the constitution
and to make belarus a basis for the
nuclear weapons of russia
everybody will understand
the importance of this decision
and the dangerous escalation of the
conflict
conflict when russia is putting in high
alarm high alert
high
alert duty its misnuclear missiles and
its fleet in the pacific and in the
baltic
well in order
to be coherent
we will
further strengthen our sanctions package
against the belarus regime
and all those who cooperate with the
russian military regressions against
ukraine
as i said yesterday we adopted an
unprecedented support package under the
european peace facility to help
ukrainian armed forces to defend
ukraine's territorial integrity
and this was done in a record time
i started working on this proposal after
the european union council
immediately after the european union
council i started thinking that enough
was not enough
that we could do more
and after the foreign affairs ministers
when we had decided finally to put putin
on the list and la brothe from the list
of sanctioned people
but we were not able to decide on the
financial measures related to take swift
russia out of swift
we start thinking that we should be
doing more
and
immediately we start
preparing this decision
which in one hand
mobilize resources to help military to
ukraine which is as i said yesterday
a turning point
on the history of european integration
because until now it was considered the
european union which is a peace union
not a military union was not allowed to
supply arms to a third country
that's what we are doing now
this is another taboo that falls
and secondly and tomorrow the parliament
will discuss about it that the military
has been informed
about the decision that will put the
strong strong toll
on the
russian economy
because to cut
half of the reserves
of the russian central bank is going to
be very damaging
but today the defense ministers
work a lot on the coordination of the
efforts in order to make
effective all bilateral initiative
together with our funding
and we had created a clearinghouse
to keep track
of the ukrainian request in one site
and their
needs and our f office member estas
offers
in order to ensure maximum effectiveness
and coordination of our support
and in doing so this cell this
clearinghouse cell will be working in
coordination with nato
ukraine has been asking also
support
for geospatial intelligence
and we are mobilized our
satellite center which is placed in
madrid to work on that
so i think that from the mobilization of
resources everything is on track
it has to be done quickly because the
war continues
the world cannot wait for bureaucratic
procedures
and i think that our answer
and our
overcoming of the institutional
difficulties has been quick
and showing
a new era in our relations with russia
and one of the things that the european
union has to do is to decrease as quick
as possible its dependency on oil and
russia russian oil and gas
we pay a very high bill
to put in
and this money
is being used to finance its military
aggression
i want also to differentiate between
putin and putin regime
and the russian people
we are sure that the russian people
don't want this
wall it is a war
that started
by putin
and by putin regime with the clique of
oligarchs
who are supporting him
and we are strongly convinced that one
of the best way of fighting is to fight
against the black money
issue from corruption that supports the
people who support putin
and on the measures taken yesterday and
approved by
legislative procedures by the commission
at the proposal of the commission and
the high representative
an important package of these measures
are
addressed
to fight the money that these people
this oligarch have
on the in our banks and our financial
systems
and i am very happy to
know that switzerland has
joined us
on the implementation of this package
because without the participation of
switzerland
our measures would have been not as much
effective as needed
but that's a very good news
that switzerland joins the efforts of
the european union
to fight financially and to fight
against corruption and to fight against
the entire money
the black money of the oligarchs who are
supporting putin tada being targeted by
our sanctions and they will continue
being targeted by our sanctions
we'll talk later more about how to fight
against corruption because corruption is
part also
of the challenges we have to face
we also worried about the situation in
other countries of the neighborhood
mainly moldova and georgia
and
i am heading for cheese now
on wednesday
to meet with the moldovan authorities
and meet with ukrainian people who have
been forced by putin aggression to leave
their homes
and look
for help
for shelter
their need of assistance in moldova
but moldova it's mainly
one of the countries in which we believe
that the russian pressure can be
increasing
on the coming days
also in the western belgians
as i announced on friday
i decided to mobilize the reserve of the
althea operation
and up to now 500 men's and women will
reinforce this force on the ground
i thank the countries who will be
providing this reinforcement of our
capacity
to control the situation and
through the operation of thea i think
it's a prudent and proportionate sign
of our determination to maintain the
stability at bosnia herzegovina
and face possible destabilization
activities by russia in the balkans
all that shows that we have been able to
react quickly and in unity
all that shows the importance of
advancing towards the adoption of this
strategic compass
that guane presented was a way to stress
that europe needs and awake
from the security
and defense dimension
that our effort on security and defense
has to be more evident
from this point of view i welcome the
decision by germany
to take important steps on increasing
their defence capacities
but the increase on defense capabilities
of the member state of the european
union has to be done in a coordinated
manner
because all together our defenses spend
the choice four times four times to
defend expenditure of russia
and equal to the one of china
but certainly
we cannot say that is equally efficient
so we have to spend more but overall we
need to spend better
an europe is the framework in which this
increase on the efficiency of our
military expenditure has to take place
we have no other choice
but they stand together as european
union
in support of ukraine
keeping in mind that is not just
supporting the ukrainian people it's
also supporting our security
and also the stability of the world
peace is going to have a price
this is not a free lunch
sanctions will backlash
sanctions have a cost
and it's better to express and to
explain to our public opinion
that this is the truth
but we have to be ready to pay this
price now
because if not we will have to pay a
much bigger price
in the future
i think it's important to face that with
determination
and realism
we are turning a page on the history of
the european integration and also in the
history of europe in the post-war war
and in the post-cold war
the relations with russia
will no more be determined by trade
believing that trade will make a
political transformation of the regime
we want to support the russian people
i am just recording a message another
message to the russian people we don't
want to fight with them we want just to
defend ukraine first
and a way of living after
in front of the russian aggression i am
wrong saying the russian aggression
it's better to say from the putin
aggression and the putin regime
aggression
which is antithetic
with ours
values
and that's why we are standing behind
the people of ukraine
thank you hi representative and now i
will take questions and i have quite a
lot in the room and
remotely i will start by yuri
not many questions because it's [ __ ]
thank you very much nabila hi
representative i have questions of
course on
the uh support to armed forces of
ukraine can you tell us a little bit
more what was discussed today of what
will be delivered to ukraine and for
example will there be
missile defenses because we see that
russia is using missiles to attack also
ukrainian cities and civilians
and
the second question uh can you tell us
also
was it discussed how to deliver this aid
to ukraine we know that uh there is a
land border of course with eu member
states but as russia has these uh
missile comp missiles
uh like iskandar missiles in belarus and
is using it so how to protect this uh
delivery of this little aid to ukraine
so that ukraine can use it thank you
very much
um midi i'm going to speak spanish
because it's more natural for me to
answer these questions
you know
you need to do you know what does it
mean
oil
okay merci
now i go to the
colleagues remotely and thomas has
raised the first hand
application of all diplomatic mercy
my french is not excellent but i will
try to say in french
[Music]
[Music]
no
is this now me yes please you have the
floor
hi thanks very much and naomi o'leary
irish times
i have two quick questions if i could
high representative
the first one is about cyber attacks can
you confirm any cyber attacks of
russian origin
for example we've had a major attack on
toyota as one example
um
the second question is about hidden
assets
um in every harbor of the mediterranean
there are mega yachts proudly flying the
flags of tax havens
where their ownership is concealed by
shell companies and many of their
owners are russian oligarchs whose names
are very well known
um will how will we identify the
ownership of those will they be affected
will they be seized
and what about cryptocurrencies are
there any steps taken um given the
design of crypto to be peer-to-peer and
to evade regulation thank you
um
foreign
um
[Music]
if it is easy
thomas your question is easy or no and
fast
yes it would be easy i was going to ask
about fighter judge but
answered so um
you've mentioned also yesterday about
the poland serving as a hub for this
military help you help for the ukraine
and today ministers decided as you said
on
creating the the clearing house is the
same how how how did it work how many
people and where geographically it would
work yeah thank you
thank you
no una camara de compensation instrument
financiero
[Music]
is
lorenzo constructs canoes uh hi
representative i i will appreciate your
answer in spanish because your spanish
is beautiful
uh i
but i ask it in english because my
spanish is not as beautiful
we are now in in in an escalation a
clear escalation uh with this uh
military answer
uh
from from the eu the first time it
happens uh military support for for the
ukrainian my question is
how can we keep
energy
out of this it's clear that for the
russians now
energy could become a way i mean cutting
energy a way to uh
to to to damage the eu because we have
uh 40 percent of our energy coming from
russia so
how can energy remain outside all these
things
man
the energy will not be
out of this conflict
like it or not
we have a dependency on russian oil and
gas
we are going to decrease this dependency
as quick as possible
and this is an existential policy to
decrease the dependency
which has been increasing by the way in
the last years
for years we have been talking about
decreasing decreasing and we have been
increasing increasing
well that's time to decrease
seriously
it means renewables
and nitrogen
very much
but it's going to be turbulences on the
markets of energy
it's easy to understand
it will happen
it's
happening and it will increase prices
and prices will be paid by consumers
maybe we can introduce subsidies
policies to project to protect the most
vulnerable
but we are in a situation in which and
that's what i was saying at the
beginning
our actions and reactions against russia
will have economic consequences
and we have to be prepared for that
don't believe that we can do whatever we
need to do
without having consequences
look the consequences
that ukrainian people are paying
they are paying a lot of consequences
they are resisting
and thank god zalensky is no kind is not
the kind of the leader
that escapes hidden in the car
no he will stay there resisting
and we have to support him
and he's going to have a cost
and if we don't pay this cost today
we'll pay much more tomorrow
that's clear
thank you
on this note i would like to thank you
very much
and
thanks
to the interpreter and i'm sorry for all
those who i couldn't take
questions
from